what would it take for an Avenger star
to call it quits at least for now keep
watching to find out about the
Revelation Thor himself had which is
giving him pause about acting for the
foreseeable future Australian actor
Chris Hemsworth has been entertaining
fans of superhero action thriller comedy
and drama films since the late 2000s
despite some early hesitations to her
career in Hollywood after his role in
2009 Star Trek Emsworth soldiered on and
eventually thrived in the movie industry
with one blockbuster film after the next
his many acting credits include several
entries in a Marvel Cinematic Universe
starting in phase one with his role in
2011's Thor despite his propensity for
occasionally branching out into serious
Cinema such as his role as Formula One
Legend James Hunt in 2013's biographical
Sports drama Rush the actor will always
come back around to please his genre
fans in a 2011 interview with interview
magazine Hemsworth commented I loved the
stuff as a kid I loved any fantasy I
grew up in a household with two brothers
and we lived in the bush we were
constantly building weapons and Forts
and things but I didn't set out to be an
action hero even if action movies found
their way to him the extraction star is
collected a vast amount of fans in the
last decade and a half first the actors
decided to slow down his output after
discovering that he is genetically
predisposed to Alzheimer's disease here
are the details while filming thaw love
and thunder Chris Hemsworth was also
intermittently filming what would become
the Disney plus documentary series
Limitless the six-part program follows
the actor across different outdoor
locations as he puts his body through
different Trials of endurance in a
journey to learn about the science of
Aging in an interview with Good Morning
America clips of Limitless were shown
including the Revelation through a
scientific test that Hemsworth has
predisposed to developing Alzheimer's
when asked if he was apprehensive about
taking the test Hemsworth replied to be
honest I didn't know what the test was
at the time the idea was that we were
going to do a deep dive into my blood
work and look at genetics and on camera
tell me what they found we didn't expect
to find much when asked if that was the
first time he found out about the health
risk the actor answered that he did so
off camera he then divulged that it is
not a predetermined genetic certainty
but rather an indicator that places him
in a high risk category for acquiring
the illness in the future speaking about
the indication Chris Hemsworth also
revealed that the news was enough to
have pushed the actor to want to take a
break from his career to spend time with
his wife and children discovering or
becoming acquainted with the fragility
of life is often enough to make any of
us prioritize spending time with those
we love and cherish which seems to have
rubbed off on the Red Dawn star as well
but Hemsworth also hopes that his
experiences in the reality series as
well as his sharing of the Alzheimer's
risky faces is enough to help Inspire
others to take better care of their
health he shared look if this is a
motivator for people to take better care
of themselves and also understand that
there are steps you can take then
fantastic the actor then stated how his
main concern was avoiding a need to
overly dramatize the Health Report his
openness also inspired the show's
executive producer Darren Aronofsky in
an interview with IGN the filmmaker said
of Hemsworth I think one of the
beautiful things about the show is how
open Chris is throughout it he was
really vulnerable and he really gave a
lot of focus to it and a lot of access
to it and it's rare that you find find a
movie star who was so willing to be
human
[Music]